Film Courage: You said you've written
everything you possibly can for money.
I'm curious what's the difference between
writing for money and not writing for money?
Andy Guerdat, Television Writer, Producer,
Instructor, and Podcaster: Well, that's a
great question. The difference between writing
for money and not writing for money is more than
just being a mercenary, I'm a working writer which
means I make a living or have made a living for 45
years writing. Other than teaching I haven't I
don't have a day job. I never have since I sold
my first script so I have to write what sells.
I have to write what people are paying money for
so that means I'm often writing something that
isn't my first choice. I spent the last 20 years
to a large degree writing children's animation.
Well I wouldn't have chosen to write children's
animation but that was what was paying so I
learned how to do it and I've enjoyed it and
I've done some very good work doing so that's one
distinction is I'm not all I write my own projects
separately not for money I'll write spec scripts
continue to do it always have sometimes they sell
sometimes they don't probably more often than not
spec scripts don't sell but that's me that's me
putting my best work uh into the world but when
I write for money I'm trying to execute someone
else's vision as well as I possibly can that's the
one distinction but it's not quite as cold-blooded
as all that because when you write for money that
means you're writing for a form that the producer
thinks will get that money back the money he's put
into it plus more plus a profit by definition that
means you're writing for an audience there have
to be people out there who are going to watch
this and that's great training because left to
their own devices all writers are going to tend
to get lost in their own head and just write
what they want to write and that's fine but
they're often disconnect from the audience if you
haven't had the experience of watching an audience
see your work I've been lucky enough to have that
experience hundreds of times and it's been good
for me to see what audiences like what audiences
don't like what they respond to what they don't
respond to how they respond is great training and
I wish every writer could have that experience I
have friends who are major screenwriters but they
may have only had four or five movies made in
their entire 20-30 years and even then very often
it wasn't really their movie somebody rewrote it
or the director changed it and they and so they
have a limited amount of experience seeing an
audience respond to their work and what because I
have had that experience because I've written for
money on TV shows or TV movies or movie movies
but because audiences responded to it and I was
in my job my paycheck depended on me satisfying
those audiences because of that I've been more
in touch with the audience than I usually than
than most most screenwriters probably are I'm
curious do you recall any interesting sort of
conversations where you've actually sat in and
heard positive and negative and how that changed
you or affected further storytelling positive or
negative from the audience you mean right right
if you've been fly on the wall yeah for sure in
terms of I did spent much of my career early in
my career it's about 20 years doing multi-camera
sitcoms and I don't know if that's a common term
everybody knows but multi-camera sitcoms are
shot with four cameras on a sound stage like
Friends or Frasier, Everybody Loves Raymond,
that kind of thing and there's an audience behind
those cameras responding to the scenes as if they
were a play they're performed like a play scene
by scene well because of that 20 years 22 episodes
of a season that's a lot of of episodes that I
either wrote or co-wrote or worked on seeing an
audience respond and so especially in comedy what
you're looking for is that verbal reaction a laugh
if you get a laugh it's great if you don't it's
usually not good so in terms of that very often
I'm constantly adjusting we might adjust between
takes very often when typical multi-camera sitcom
you do two takes usually sometimes three but
usually two takes of a scene and even in the
5-10 minutes between each take when the actors
are being touched up for their makeup and every
cameras are going back to position one the the
writers and producers are rushing in to try
and fix the joke or tweak this or make it work
better so it was a constant process and I also
learned that laughter isn't the only way to read
an audience that I had a boss once who said all I
want in that first scene I'd love to have a laugh
in the first scene but if I just get a gasp or a
moan or something that suggests they're engaged
in the story or gold that's what you're looking
for you're looking for are they engaged in the
story are they leaning in are they interested
in whatever the protagonist problem is and so it
could come in the form of a laugh but any kind
of response like that is more useful it's the most
useful thing any writer can have a dramatic writer
much more useful than a focus group for example
where focus groups of any kind are false there
because you're asking people to put into verbal
responses what they felt and the average audience
member is not capable of doing that there's
no reason to expect them to be able to do
that it's hard for anybody to be able to say what
it was they felt half an hour ago when they watch
something they just can't do it and it's usually
not very useful watching them live is the best.
Film Courage: Andy, you recently started a YouTube
channel and it's The Go Draft By Andy Guerdat,
you say the world doesn't need more
screenwriters it needs better movies?
Andy: Yeah, that's part of my philosophy for doing
it in the first place. I'm not selling a book,
I'm not selling a seat in a seminar, I just want
to see better movies. I'm a bit of an old grouch
I guess but I don't think I'm alone in saying that
there aren't a lot of great movies anymore. We're
lucky to see one a year, literally one good movie
a year much less the barrage of great films that I
grew up watching in the in the 70s, especially
when I came of age as a film watcher and fell
in love with films every week there'd be two or
three great films released and now it's there's
a paucity, there's just a lack of of good movies
because I believe the craft of screenwriting has
fallen to such a low level there's a lot of
reasons for it doesn't really matter why but
my goal here is just to share what I know and I
have learned a lot over 45 years of getting paid
to do this I have learned a lot about how to
tell stories in the filmic medium so that's my
goal I just want to share it and and I had taught
have taught for a number of years at UCLA and at
Pepperdine Universities but I also when I was
working up until recently I still do go in as a
consultant at Disney still but up until recently
I was a day-to-day television writer and a head
writer and so I was found myself teaching in to
the staffs who were desperate for this material
even though most of them been to film school the
screenwriting instruction they'd received was not
particularly good so or at least it wasn't useful
to them and so I realized there was a there was
a market for this I'm not interested in try
at this point in my career I'm comfortable I
don't need to monetize it I just want to share
it and and if it's a value to someone seems to
be to a lot of people what I know why not get
it out there in the world and that's what The
Go Draft is all about the term Go Draft by the
way because people ask what does that mean it
used to be common in Hollywood I don't know
if it is anymore but they talked about the go
draft was the draft that was written that got
the green light whoever wrote The Go Draft was
a prized commodity very often they weren't even
credited but they they did that last pass that
made the the made the script go from promising
to okay let's start writing checks we're going
to make this film and that's a lot of who I'm
writing it for people who are probably already
interested or even actively trying to be a writer
a screenwriter but their work isn't quite up to
the level of getting shot of getting paid of
getting moving on to the next level of getting
your work produced and so that's hence the go
draft going back to the idea of maybe there's
less quality films made today do you think that
we watch films for different reasons sometimes
we have things playing in the background that
we're not too emotionally invested in it's pretty
light it's pretty maybe the people are pretty and
others we go by ourselves and we maybe we're not
in the best mood but we want to feel something to
take us out of where we are and other people want
to be sort of it's a date movie they don't want
anything too serious we go for different reasons
yeah that's that's absolutely true I think it's
probably always been true I mean I there were
when you look back at the history of Hollywood
movies there were romantic comedies and musicals
and dramas and film noir and all kinds of things
so the difference is especially in the last well
since streaming especially even before that the
fragmentation of the market through cable but
as more and more people began to experience 2hour
films feature length films at home rather than in
the theater it forces the screenwriter to capture
the audience quicker we don't have as much time as
we used to I think Robert Towne used to talk about
you had 10 15 minutes before anybody was going to
start talking about leaving so you've got them
for well that's not true anymore you don't have
you have for 10 or 15 seconds anymore you have to
capture people more quickly and that's true but
that's not the certainly not the reason why the
craft has has gotten as sloppy and ragged as it
has most films that don't work the vast majority
of them don't work because of the script because
no this they never got the story right or maybe
they did get the story right but then producers
and stars and other directors started monkeying
with it and pulled it out of shape very rarely
are are films failures because they're poorly
directed or because it's not shot well or because
the costumes are wrong or even if the casting is
wrong certainly can affect how effective they are
but that's not usually the reason why a film fails
it's almost always the problems are in the script.